french police shadowed a lone migrant
boat
a royal navy drone searched for others
on a sunny calm day you might have
expected a lot of illegal migrants
taking a chance
we saw some but nothing like the
hundreds on previous days a bit too
early perhaps to say the government's
new policy to send illegal migrants to
rwanda was already deterring the traffic
across the channel everybody is leaving
what are fundamentally safe countries
there are perfectly functioning asylum
systems in france and in other eu
countries and people should be using
them when they're in those countries
rather than making these perilously
unsafe journeys so we have to take steps
to address this that's precisely what we
are doing and i think that this is an
important intervention that dramatically
shifts the dynamic whilst also providing
opportunities and sanctuary in rwanda
for individuals who wish to have that
the old manston airfield near margate is
now the first new home for cross-channel
asylum seekers they spend several days
here some were on the move though it
wasn't clear if they knew exactly where
they were headed next
border force staff were monitoring their
movements if these new arrivals don't
know already that their next stop might
well be rwanda they certainly will soon
royal navy ships were on patrol for a
second day
the channel migrant operation is now
under the command of the ministry of
defence it gives us much greater
bandwidth if you like to um manage the
maritime border than we had when the
border force were doing it alone because
of course the royal navy brings huge
assets not just shipping but also huge
surveillance assets and gives us more
opportunity to be able to spot
vessels in the water as they approach
the uk border
it was a quiet day in the channel
no one expects it to stay like that
martin brunt sky news kent